an exclusive interview with face to
nation ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky called the atrocities a
genocide and then outlined a stark
choice
for the west
we have been talking
for such a long
time that nato
that ukraine cannot be
a part of nato and
they keep emphasizing
this to us when they're saying that nato
countries cannot
transfer
everything they want to us because nato
countries cannot be part of this war
although i would like to repeat this
again that you cannot stand in the
middle between the evil
and the good
the white and the black this won't
happen you still have to take sides
face to nation moderator and chief
foreign affairs correspondent margaret
brennan joins us now margaret good
morning
we heard president zielinski used the
word genocide our secretary of state
anthony blinken hesitated would not use
that word in describing the scenes out
of buca and elsewhere in ukraine i'm
curious to know why you think he holds
back on that term and also these images
what do they do uh to the pressure level
that the us and its allies are facing to
try to stop what's happening in ukraine
well tony you know the president of
ukraine
used the word very strongly with great
passion but you heard the united states
secretary of state as you just said have
cautioned because there is a strict
legal definition there have been only
eight times in u.s history the american
government has actually recognized that
a genocide's taking place because in
part it's difficult you have to show
proof of intent to destroy a group
but it's happened before just a few
weeks ago in fact the biden
administration declared there is a
genocide underway in asia in a country
called burma they recognize right now
there is a genocide underway against
muslims uyghurs in china so he could
choose to initiate this process at the
state department and formally
recognize it genocide under
international law became illegal after
the holocaust in 1946
and whenever you use that word tony it
begs the question
what are you going to do about it
and that's the problem here that is one
of the challenges particularly for the
secretary of state as he heads to nato
this week uh because it will add to
pressure to act
yeah and there are already sanctions
there already weapons transfers uh the
secretary of state did point out while
he's not using that term the evidence is
being gathered and that legal process
you mentioned is being followed margaret
thank you very much